bon les chéri e j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle
vient de recevoir un classement qui m'a
fait froid dans le dos et sur nous les
français à franck sosie ch en allemand
frank la wii en a oui
les chéris parmi les 25 pays de l' ocde
comme chacun le sait signifie
l'organisation de coopération et
développement économiques ocde
tu peux te savoir fait pas de mal dans
cet émirat
il ya un sondage qui est sorti
et nous sommes le pays parmi les 25
le pays le plus radin lausseignan les
français sont les plus radins donne pas
on est content ou pas sont
officiellement les consommateurs les
plus économes et les plus raisonnable en
termes de dépenses alors pour on est
devenus les plus radins ouais un émoi
mais les plus malins
non mais c'est vrai est ce que ça vous
choque non non qui est extrêmement rada
autour de cette table
s'il vous plaît non mais un qui fait
attention barrabande parce qu'ils
achètent est-ce qui est généreux pour
lui mais peu généreux pour les autres
alors que mathieu n'est pas que non non
non non je suis pas calais principal
défaut de mathieu noms
ne vous disent quelque chose que les
gens l'ignorent oui quand je leur dis
tout beaucoup de chroniqueurs notamment
kelly viennent souvent me consulter pour
devenir de meilleurs profs du
chroniqueur à l'antenne
former un cabinet
vous l'avez déjà dit ce que des
consultations média jeu franchement mes
horaires c'est 400 euros leur corps et
l'avocat sarthe aux cavs d'oncologie de
me demande du charisme valérie d'avoir
des avis
kelly de trois feuilles venez me voir et
je n'ai jamais fait payer jamais jamais
jamais elle m'a offert un coca passa
rien rien rien non franchement voilà
kelly est un petit peu radine parce que
je l'aide beaucoup et elles ne meurent
en rien en route mais est-ce que c'est
pas gratuit et oussalah mes contacts oui
la consultation non pas que la rive nord
alors maintenant cet acharnement mathieu
oh là là où
elle est blonde in hélas le groupe abba
[Applaudissements]
et encore un autre membre qui
n'engagerait preuve que mathieu est une
énorme pince
longtemps j'ai déjeuné avec lui alors
j'ai réglé l'addition il a pris le
ticket pour sereinement
[Applaudissements]
je veux que les marches sombre et toutes
les faces ils sont présentés pour quel
motif une info de ouf allez-y j'ai
appris que mathieu
[Rires]
quoi lorsque mathieu va au restaurant
oui donc souvent dans paris des beaux
restaurants parce que mathieu a beaucoup
de goût comme on le sait ouais à la fin
quand il a terminé de manger il rote
qu'est ce qui dit aux serveurs ouais
c'est honteux il dit lui chez matthieu
delormeau il dit est-ce que je vous dois
quelque chose
[Rires]
j'ai entendu ça et franchement je me
suis dit est ce qu'un jour
on va en parler parce que moi ça me
tenait à coeur à savoir mais pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'il avait en tête pour avoir
ce sens qu'il a en tête c'est papy
personnes âgées est-ce que l'accusé peut
répondre l'accusé alors on va faire déjà
le tour d'une accusation
alors sur matthieu delormeau toujours
aller doucement maintenant vous savez
que il est beaucoup de voitures même
fait le tour de toutes les concessions
de paris à on se faire prêter des
voitures gratuitement et il les rend
systématiquement sans le plein d'essence
[Musique]
bré et qu'on sait si vous avez vous
aussi des infos sans mathieu delormeau
et sa radinerie un numéro azur s'affiche
à l'écran vous nous appelez elle
n'agissait pas seul
si vous êtes dans la région parisienne
et que vous croisez matthieu delormeau
prévenait tout de suite les autorités
cet individu dangereux on peut peut-être
vous prendre de l'oseille
ou une voiture ou une frite
quoi que ce soit je vous le dis c'est un
professionnel n'agissait pas d'aider les
autorités
libanaises il nous faut sur matthieu
delormeau mari mais une vraie info ben
ouais s'attaquer aux restaurateurs c'est
terrible et s'attaquaient à vous je ne
laisserai pas passer ce qu'il a fait
ouais en loge ah oui en ce moment oui il
est en train de monter une mutinerie
[Rires]
de mutinerie alors je vous explique tout
maintenant l'heure c'est un petit sms en
disant que vous étiez content de nous
vous étiez au courant c'est
parce voir son nom soit révélé sur les
voilà sur la rue alors qu'il a reçu
radio la radio est voilà tu l'a reçue
kelly oui mais si il attend reçu mathieu
est au courant il est venu nous voir en
loges qu'ils étaient là et nous a dit
les gars et il est bien gentil cyril
mais on s'en fou qu'on soit bon ce qu'on
veut c'est une augmentation migron qu'il
est en train de nous monter kelly monde
a évidemment refusé bien sûr on a une
voix bien sûr vous avez vous demandé en
cours de saison mais ce qui est honteux
jamais pour deux saisons une
augmentation et nous a même dit demandé
70 euros de plus comme ça moi je demande
mais c'est faux je n'ai demandé que pour
moi c'est fou ça cyril je ne laisserai
pas partie d une mutinerie c'est faux
c'est une rétine effet les élus mais la
chute je confirme tout et il a même
continué sur la même lancée elle dit il
a dit je suis toujours d'ailleurs super
fâché pour l'argent qu'on a tous les
mois je trouve que c'est un scandale et
j'aimerais organiser une pétition
consigne tous poils plus d'oseille pour
s'acheter des fringues
série de jeux complète il part
systématiquement et toutes les fringues
du stylisme car il est vrai moi aussi
m
c'est
que des fruits ouais c'est vrai et les
propos d'ailleurs cette phrase et
légumes par cinq par cinq mais sept
alors moi mais demande un cabas mûri
carrément suffit
il à 18h54 des trains directs et ce que
vous muer ce soir doit vous glace ils
sont
je me vois votre place chez vous et vous
vous dites comment un individu au civil
[Musique]
peut encore vivre en société ce sont des
fruits qu'il est perdu
sachez qu'il n'ya aucun fruit perdu ah
oui alors ici tous les fruits trouvent
preneurs cela dit vu le coût du
restaurant sûr je te jure à une fois sur
trois dans sa marque sa page du disque
sata je dois quelque chose cette saveur
et un petit peu gêné dit merde et or le
patron et une fois sur trois à peu près
il revient et dit non nous sommes très
heureux
c'est quand ils déjeunent pas avec moi
c'est horrible pour moi c'est horrible
c'est de mon image et me donnent leur
nourrice
est ce que j'ai déjà fait ça mon chien
mais c'est un peu mou jarry mais j'avais
un minimum et les exemples après moi
j'ai un problème au restaurant qu'elle
immobilise c'est ben haim aussi qu'il y
voilà c'est à dire que j'arrive je sais
pas attendre par exemple le jeu ça y va
je m'assois direct ntap je crois qu'en
fait il faut pas que c'est pas en
fait il ya près de chez moi parce que je
m'assoie dirais que c'est ce site mais
je n'oublie qu'il ya des gens qui ont
réservé tu vois c'est le seul truc je
suis donc extrêmement courtois et vous
laisser des gros pourboires oui crowley
bah oui bah quoi alors question
d'éducation ne le savait pas mais
le plaisir de le savoir
moi j'ai déjeuné deux fois avec machin
[Rires]
réservez qu'a choisi le restaurant et ça
me fait très plaisir et de l'a10 d'abord
amener de la soupe à madame parce
qu'elle peut manger que ça
arrivait au dessert il a dit ben bella
note c'est évidemment pour la vieille
parce que déjà que c'est bien gentil de
déjeuner avec
thibaut privat notre nom
a déjeuné avec moi alors est dernier
avec moi je lui donne de mon temps elles
payent leurs efforts
on vit ce soit est horrible et je sais
que vous aussi chez vous ou vite qu'elle
espère saint louis c'est matthieu
delormeau les actions de leurs mères est
ce que pour vous oui vous êtes généreux
alors jésus mais est ce que vous
connaissez la définition de l'année
générosité avait tranché que vous
associez générosité argent va oui bah
oui ah oui et l'arrière morosité du
coeur
des mots celle de l'amitié effectivement
je n'ai pas payé avec mamie mais on a
parlé on a passé un bon moment j'ai
donné beaucoup de moi on appelle moi
témoigne
ton temps mais ton amitié oui mais après
ils t'ont attention à après je m'arrange
pour qu'il en rentre plus qu'il n'en
sorte d'accord voilà
je vous parlais argent là
souvent déjeuner où on a vu souvent à
les arrêter de leurs mots ou là moi non
plus souvent oui non et trois fois avec
willy brandt à quoi ça va être un moment
il a au ne serait-ce alors moi je sens
mes chevaux virez moi j'ai un truc
dégueulasse c'est horrible c'est qu'à
chaque fois que quelqu'un des jeunes
avec moi ouais qu'il soit 1 2 3 4 5 10
15 ou 20 ça veut dire que les gars je
vous jure que c'est vrai c'est horrible
c'est à dire que les gars mange et se
saluent
alors genre non c'est à dire que c'est
toujours j'ai toujours moi qui habite
mais comme dans la campagne mais pas les
deux restaurants un gars que benjamin
fall c'est exactement et malheureusement
la carte n'est pas passé
[Applaudissements]
non mais moi mais c'est vrai que moi
j'adore naviguer je vous jure que je
descende bon concept appelé à doha c'est
mon kiff non mais c'est vrai que je suis
gêné en fait je suis gêné quand on m'a
vite j'ai pas mal voyagé j'ai pas envie
de manger si on dirait un truc je
regarde et on préfère dire je paye et
lui d'imaginer un non sens après moi je
fais pas des restaurants de ouf non plus
hein ah ouais c'est vrai que le menu mac
do s'est pas non plus
privé rarement dans les trois étoiles je
suis jamais dit par exemple dans un
trois étoiles mon avance un truc merde
n'ont jamais et vous vérifié on devait y
aller que le couvent est d'empêcher à
huy mashaei pas nous diriger la nation
non franchement non mais non mais c'est
vrai que moi je vois la chose ni j'ai
rarement des très bons et je vais que
dans des restaurants voilà puis derrière
nous avons trouvé en cette période vous
avez pas les restos nettement à la fin
on est prêt à me battre et je veux pas
quoi ça ne fait pas
ça sinon adieu non non mais non alors
les chéris mais non mathieu lui voulait
dire un truc maintenant c'est quelque
chose qui m'a touché pour vous vous avez
quand même dit que les gens partent se
lève et que c'est logique pour eux que
c'est vous qui payez non je crois que
vous avez vu que non mais c'est une
logique pour eux et je crois que vous
avez soulevé quelque chose qui vous
tient à coeur un lièvre et si vous
voulez nous en parler on peut en
discuter
et vraiment moi ça me chagrine pour vous
que les gens se lèvent ça
mérite une blessure à la roseraie j'ai
ressenti blessure parce que si
c'est vraiment ça vous dérange les gens
t'aiment pour qu'ils tuent elles
n'ont
pas vous êtes heureux de dire que les
gars des jeunes avec moi que je vais
payer ce que vous avez dit c'est parce
que je suggérais c'est que j'aime bien
c'est comme ça sans faire attention à ce
que cet égard un geste en balade en
partage pas coutume habite dans le sud
si tu n'as pas de bateau je viens pas
je vous ai dans ma vie mais c'est pas
faux
alors les shihri journée je suis à midi
je vous dis un classement qui a offert
trois dans le dos puisque cet après midi
j'ai demandé au chroniqueur à chaque
chroniqueur de me donner le top 3 les
plus gros radin de l'émission carbone
pourrait faire la différence entre ce
que les gens voient à l'écran et la
réalité des comportements des
chroniqueurs en vente est alors j'ai
demandé aussi notre en fait j'ai demandé
d'ailleurs au public ardeurs vous aussi
et j'ai le classement des plus ingénieux
donc peut-être bout nous persuade où
vous êtes persuadé que ça y est tu peux
être que le public ait décidé à
voir si vous perçoivent comme radan
c'est un vrai sondage mais sachez
comme je ne peux pas être juge et partie
je n'ai pas proposé mon nom pour le
classement
des bienfaits
en 9e position la moins radine
jamais il n'a pas été cité une seule
fois par ses camarades
ces personnes c'est géraldine maillet
géraldine maillet 9 personne n'a dit que
vous étiez radine ah ouais mais c'est
vrai je suis très généreuse c'est vrai
pas moi je n'ai toujours pas vu mais bon
j'attends non non non je redis c'est
compliqué mais janeiro avec son patron
qui moquent souvent des livres bof
souvent des choux ouais et j'ai jamais
fait des cadeaux à nos anniversaires
c'est vrai mais vous avez de la chance
oui non mais chez jean louis chamla
n'est pas cité vous n'avez pas été sympa
merci beaucoup mes camarades en huitième
position
c'est isabelle d'une offre car
[Rires]
attention
il s'appelle vous avez une grosse numéro
8 c'est vrai à vous savez quoi non sans
vous le savez à chaque fois c'est un
combat moi j'ai établi le truc un jour
tu m'invites après ces mois à 5 ans et
moi l effet elle fait tout pour payer
ses incroyables très belle anecdote
en septième position plus radars c'est
un homme c'est ça va il s'en sort bien
face là on est dans les mois rabat et
bernard montiel est ressorti bien
bernard masset vraiment une mascarade
allawi
mais là et là dessus je ne suis pas
d'accord
il est il est extrêmement radin
et rémy thierry
comment on peut rien [ __ ] pendant 40
ans et richesses que vous avez là sur
tf1 ah oui
mais c'est vrai qu'ils dépensent pas
beaucoup parce que c'est vrai il allait
partout l'excellent entre les deux là
ils ont un magot les deux
dosages aussi oui non ya pas un gros
magot morvan je vais vous dire
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord je remercie mes camarades parce
qu'ils n'ont pas tort non non je suis
très enfin je sais pas c'est difficile
de dire quand les généraux ou pas on va
observer que cette beaucoup de gens
autour de moi il faudra doubler montrer
1 en sixième position valérie bella ils
savent où ils ont sorti après sa 5e
position
kelly b novelli là on rentre dans le top
5 des plus vous êtes s'attendait
alors ce classement on va vraiment à huy
à la vous allez voir parce que caster on
va y arriver on va bientôt arriver dans
le top 3 des plus rares à caster
kelly est 5ème et 4ème position c'est
gilles verdez a un ça va l'hiver n'est
pas
beau raté la médaille de bronze à paul
bocuse c'est un immonde rage et à verser
à la production de circulaires alors là
on va voir tout de suite pas du tout non
plus arrêté c'est un classement du plus
radin en troisième position et vous
allez découvrir chez vous le top 3 des
plus radin
plus tard mais vu populaire l'autre est
une première les stars peut dire des
conneries en abolition guillaume genton
alors là ah oui pas perçue comme une
barre et je ne l'accepterai pas si on
avait fait des cadeaux magnifique bah
oui mais
non mais non me tiens il s'en sort bien
tout comme j'en tombe à java / guérisse
c'est quoi guillaume c'est quelqu'un de
très généreux à chaque service qu'on lui
demande que ce soit un gros service il
est toujours là pour vous même à la
minute près il exceptionnel le sac sous
la menace a mérité vos conneries mais ce
sont quand même en troisième place pas
du régime méritait d'être bien deux
compères des cadeaux qu'à toi
reste au toit a invité au resto espèce
de crevards
ce
n'est pas une surprise on va découvrir
le classement c'est bien sûr matthieu
delormeau et voilà non merci on va pas
faire donner une peine sur un truc voilà
c'est vous mais benjamin castaldi
deuxième je suis très
intéressé par
moi ça vous étonne pas non à non pas là
mais vous c'est comme nadal à roland
garros et
c'est juste simplement il ya une théorie
à ce truc là c'est juste parce que le
benjamin c'est juste le plus gentil de
l'équipe et tout le monde a voté contre
lui et parce qu'on savait qu'ils
seraient pas vexer
celui-ci a voté ces publics ce sont des
chroniqueurs été démonté le public
bientôt et je pense que vous serez
d'humeur ans
[Applaudissements]